[Music]
all right so the last three months right
three or four months Wild Ride for
Bitcoin also the crypto world but now
some investors are are starting to
wonder if this current pullback is an
example of either sell the news or maybe
bait and switch or bringing out PP
Investments uh Investments uh Anthony
Pompano all right I mean I mean you know
might be some buyers remorse out there
you know we have 48,000 now we're at
40,000 what happened well look there's a
huge run up in price obviously from mid
October until the actual approval so
we're sitting around $27,000 back in mid
October and almost doubled in price and
so obviously there's going to be some
profit taking I also think that people
don't quite understand all of the uh
different things that are happening in
the market in terms of grayscale right
gbtc still has a 1.5% management feed
and so there's people who are dumping
that about2 billion dollar has float out
which is more than covering the inflows
that have come in on the ETF side and so
you just have a lot of sellers at the
moment but I do think that we're seeing
so much interest in the ETFs if everyone
just Waits and chills the price will be
just fine there's always been this sort
of undercurrent that on one hand you
want the wall Wall Street involved but
on the other hand you really don't want
Wall Street involved you know what I
mean I think that there's going to be a
pre ETF era and a post ETF era when it
comes to bitcoin's history and what you
have to remember is that when you get
tons of Wall Street investors involved
and you get lots of liquidity in the
market volatility will dampen the good
news is we probably won't have a lot of
80% draw Downs anymore but the bad news
may be you may not have those asymmetric
th% gains in a single year either I I
saw something from out of Arc and it
says bitcoin's hash rate is at an
all-time high 50 EXA hashes this month
now a lot of this I don't know what the
hell I'm saying but the chart I'm a
chart guy look at that damn when I see a
chart like this I like what is that I
like it so I mean it's a positive piece
here but explain to us why this is
another reason maybe people want to
belong Bitcoin so when I ask somebody
hey you know what is the value that's
backing that asset a lot of people say
there's nothing backing Bitcoin but
actually if you think about in the
digital world the single most valuable
commodity in the world is computing
power and Bitcoin is backed by computing
power and that's what you're seeing here
is how much computing power is behind
the Bitcoin Network right what is
running this network and so bitcoin's
network is the strongest computer
network in the entire world it's faster
and it is stronger than all the
supercomputers and all the really highly
technical things Bitcoin is a
decentralized network with all this
computing power and so what does that
mean the more computing power that's
pointed towards Bitcoin the more secure
it is and the whole idea of Bitcoin is
that it's outside the system no one can
hack it no one's going to be able to
change it so when you see that chart
going up and to the right that means
that Bitcoin is actually getting
stronger the stronger the Bitcoin is the
more valuable people around world that's
part of the real actual value
proposition not just hey you know what
it's it's anti- fiat currency but that
gives that puts some real meat on the
fundamental bone yeah if you think about
what is the system behind it right
there's actual people have gone they've
bought computers they've plugged them in
they're consuming power they're turning
power into money and the more power or
the more computing power that's on that
Network the stronger it is the harder it
is to hack and so just like gold right
the more that you can physically touch
the gold the more it's in your
possession same thing here is the
network is being protected by that
computing power you want to see that
continue to go up and the right for as
much as it can before I let you go uh
Market's looking phenomenal stock
markets looking phenomenal we've had a
big run in a lot of things Commodities
may be coming on are you feeling okay
overall are you one of these people
though that gets a little antsy when
things feel too good so I I think it's
interesting the S&P hit an all-time high
we got over 5% interest rates but what I
would say is if you look at Global
liquidity that's really the driver here
and we have seen Global liquidity now is
showing a number of different signs
based on how you measure it that we are
going to see much more money slashing
around in the global economy regardless
of what the FED does and I do think that
that'll serve as a Tailwind for the next
couple of years all right love it hey my
man have a great weekend absolutely you
too thanks